[Music]  in a hot pan sweat shredded leeks along  with a knob of butter and season next  great par boiled potatoes and Greer a  heart Swiss cheese with a great nutty  flavor  then combined with a soft release in a  pan heat oil and a little butter spoon  in the potato leek and cheese mix cook  gently until golden and crisp underneath  then slide onto a plate flip over and  return to the pan to finish cooking  [Music]  finally for the perfect topping fry two  eggs and place them on top of the Rasta  top with fresh tarragon  [Music]  leaking gray arras tea with fried eggs  are simple but substantial dish that  makes the most of hearty root veg beans  come dried or in tins and there are  great cheap ingredients to make dishes  more substantial than shade gulfport  sized chunks of the mixture using a  spoon and rest in the fridge